all right in this video what i want to
talk about is um i just finished our
strategic meeting
and it was so apparent um some of the
new talent that we brought in
um how much they were really driving
growth in um in some of our companies
and i want to talk about this because i
think it's the single hardest thing that
entrepreneurs face like every single
entrepreneur has one problem they think
they have multiple problems but they
have one problem
and it's a people problem they don't
know where to find good people
number one number two they don't know
how to hire and recruit those people
number three if they don't know how to
manage those people number four they
know how to grow
uh and cultivate the talent right and so
that entire process embodies what
really growing a business becomes after
you get to probably about 10
10 to 30 million a year is when when ops
really really start taking over
especially at 30 it's all about talent
and
i think i've said this before this is
probably the big it's been the biggest
bottleneck for me crossing 30 to 100
um is was really understanding that it
was understanding that it was all about
the talent it's actually not about you
and that can be really hard for your ego
because you love being needed
and that's like an interpersonal need
that we you know have from childhood or
whatever it is we didn't get hugged
enough
but like that need is something that is
outside of the business
the business doesn't require you the
business should be able to run on its
own and this is something that has
shifted over time
um that being said it doesn't mean that
you can't have the strategic vision for
the business you know bezos just stepped
down for the first time after you know
30 years or whatever
um but but you're the actual doing the
leading all that stuff over time
the company becomes a company of
companies right it becomes a
conglomerate as you grow
and so what i want to talk about
specifically today
is how to find and know the difference
between an a
player and a b player or really an a
player and everyone else
and i can't really stress how
unbelievably important this is and the
thing is is that we've talked to
entrepreneurs they're always like my
team's awesome
and you talk the same entrepreneur a
year later and they're like that team
was horrible this team's awesome
and that's because we're eternal
optimists right that's that's just the
reality of it
if you can't look at someone on your
team and be like i think this person's
kind of weak or i think this person
could be better
um then you really have rose-colored
glasses on right and that's the hard
part and i honestly this isn't this
wasn't
real for me until i actually saw
teammates of mine
growing divisions of our companies
without me doing it in ways that i had
never thought of
once that happened it became real for me
i think there's these different steps in
your entrepreneurial journey i mean the
first one was when i remember
the first person who did a sale for me i
cried i remember i cried because i heard
about on the phone
and they're like yeah i sold two people
today and i i had done
every single sale for my business for
like a year and a half it's just it was
just no one could bring it in
right and and the answer is other people
can bring it in you're not special
um but i it wasn't real for me and as
soon as this this girl
did this i was like oh my god like
i don't have to i don't have to
literally make the money someone else
can do this
and i can actually start running the
business and so it's a huge breakthrough
um and there's obviously levels to this
right and i think
the the level that i just recently had a
breakthrough on was
watching teammates actually grow the
business um
without me right and it's really special
it's really awesome
so you're like that's awesome for you
alex why are you talking to me
great question a players and b players
so what i want to do is tell you a quick
story because i think it's
perfect for illustration so we just
recently promoted a brand manager one of
our companies
and she was given uh the task
of like hey why don't you think about
other revenue streams that we could
possibly bring into the company
and so she said i thought we should
start an apparel line because i'm
getting lots of messages on social media
about how we should have apparel
um and i think that'd be a good
opportunity and so her her supervisor
said
i think that's a great idea go for it
right and so
what she did was she emailed you know 20
different
uh you know manufacturing companies uh
for
for apparel um she got samples from all
of them
she tried them all on she felt them and
she showed up to the strategic meeting
and she was like
they were crap she was like i'm not
sending that to my customers
she said those exact words and i can't
tell you what it felt like for me as an
owner to hear that she said
i'm not sending that to my customers and
it was because it showed so much
ownership and one of our core tenants is
bureau and boss which i'm switching to
act like an owner
but that's exactly what she did and
to push it even further she didn't just
stop there and say all this stuff sucks
because that would just be presenting a
problem
instead she was like but i did find some
manufacturers
that don't do manufacturing and
fulfillment because some centers do both
which is much more convenient for me as
a business
but she's like but their stuff is legit
it's awesome
just like so i just need help figuring
out how how many pieces do you want to
order as a baseline i'll figure out the
logistics to get to a third-party
fulfillment center
so that we can do this apparel launch
and so we ended up coming with a
solution for it and she felt great about
it we looked at different you know
designs
and uh and with with the great quality
we were able to come up with a solution
but here's here's what i want to bring a
break apart for you
imagine a normal person a b b level
employee
nothing wrong with them there's lots of
them right but
they show up they do their job they go
home
right they don't take ownership because
what what an alternative story of what
would have happened
is the director says hey why don't you
look for new revenue opportunities and
that person may or may not have done
at level one right level two they
actually do it and they say i think
apparel she says okay
go check out apparel now what that
person probably would have done
was look at three companies from a
google search
maybe or maybe not even sample the
product
just look at the pricing and say hey i
found an apparel company
we can print our logo on it we can ship
it out that is what a b player would
have done
and honestly unless you have an a
supervisor the a supervisor
probably would have let it go and what
and i'll tell you the difference
the difference is with the a scenario
you have a high quality product that
people buy
enjoy and buy again and that massively
increases the ltv of the customer
and on top of that that brand manager
cares deeply about the customers and
their experience
and she's going to be thinking top of
mind how do i make this easier how do i
make this faster how can i improve their
experience
right whereas the b player
you already lost them like oh yeah they
don't like the t-shirts i mean
what do they expect right i mean like
they're 30
t-shirts i mean they're not gonna be you
know xyz
and so
that difference is the game
and finding people who think like that a
player
compared to people who think like the b
player is the difference between
companies that grow
and companies that die companies that
barely compete and make it
and companies that thrive and none of
what i just described was earth
shattering
it was just a willingness to do more
work and
raising the bar it was having a level of
intolerance
for anything but excellence and it is my
belief that within a company hierarchy
every person
the higher the person who runs the
division or the department or the
company
should always have the lowest amount of
tolerance for anything but excellence
which means you should be intolerant of
anything that is not amazing
right and that trickles down it gets
deluded right at every level it's
diluted a little bit more a little bit
more a little bit more
and if there comes a day where you see
two people and you see a supervisor and
you see someone
underneath that supervisor and the
person underneath
has a has a lower tolerance for anything
but excellence
than their supervisor those roles should
reverse
the person who cares the most should be
the one in charge
and so if there comes a day where
someone cares more about my customers
and the experience and the business that
we have than i do
they should rightfully run the company
not me and sometimes entrepreneurs get
to that point they have a ceo
and they elect them because they're like
i think that you're better equipped for
this and i think that you care more
deeply and that's okay that happens
right
you know phil knight doesn't run nike
anymore but
um i mean shoot jeff bezos says and you
obviously step down for other reasons
and what not but
the big picture here is having
a level of intolerance for what an a
versus a b looks like
starts with us and the thing is is
whoever you hire
most people only hire people worse than
them and so
if you're if you're one level removed or
two levels removed dear god
imagine what you're what's what's being
hired on the front line right
and so you have to carry this torch you
have to raise this bar you have to set
the standard
so that a players will be attracted to
you and also so that you can have a team
of a players and then the entire culture
rises
right if you've ever been on a winning
team a championship team
you know the difference between the vibe
how people come to practice how they
play
the expectations of one another right
the speed of response the teamwork all
of that
that's culture and that's only created
through having the right players on the
field the right people on the bus
and kicking off the wrong people and
i'll end with this quote
from the head of people for chick-fil-a
which is a company i
admire a lot she said a lot of companies
want to compete against us
in the championship but the reality is
they lost in the draft
and that one really resonated with me
because and
i'm paraphrasing here that might not
even be your title but that was
what she said in general and that that
really struck me
because so many of us are always trying
to develop or awesome develop talent i
was trying to do all these things
management styles etc
but some people just come with batteries
included there are some people who are
just winners
right and you just need to get out of
their way and i think that it's worth
the extra five interviews it's worth the
extra 20 interviews
to find the a player because once that
person is in place
they will grow right they will grow
whatever they touch
and this has been a deep lesson for me
which is what you know people are like
it's all about people and it is it's
just
boring and unsexy for most entrepreneurs
because we love the promotion we love
the sales we love the marketing we love
all that stuff
right we love the product but the people
is what runs it
and i think that this has been this has
been a deep lesson for me
um and i hope i hope if you look at your
team right now you don't think oh
they're all amazing
right because the reality is they're
probably not right
um and every single entrepreneur says
that i can tell you right now some
people that are weak on our team
right but you have to be honest about it
and you have to think
not just what are they doing but what
would i be doing
in their position what initiative would
i be taking that they're not taking
what questions would i be asking that
they are not asking and
ideally you want someone who's asking
questions that you haven't thought of
and that's when you know you've got an a
player so anyways this comes with time
it comes with experience it comes with
once you've seen an a player you can
never unsee them and then you start to
use that template to apply to other
people
all right and so and then you repeat it
over and over again and i think that's
why entrepreneurship takes time
like you grow you grow in levels you
grow intolerance you grow an
interpersonal understanding you grow an
awareness
of other people and by as you grow in
that awareness
so too will your selection of talent so
too will your recruitment of talent
um your management and growth of those
people so anyways
hope that made sense hope that was
valuable for you if you're hiring people
only look for eight players
put in the extra time to get the a
player because it will pay you dividends
beyond your wildest dreams
and there was a harvard study that
showed that eight players are worth five
times more than b players
and with that i'll catch you soon bye